hi I'm Ashley more north I run an
organization called NZ that looks at
innovative financing models for
education we're currently looking at
vocational training in India I this my
first time at a World Economic Forum
event and it's been an incredible
experience the economic summit I had the
chance to be on two panels including one
on game changers in education and met
some fantastic people who are working in
education and vocational training which
which was a great experience overall the
summit has been very positive it's the
first time that the global shapers the
newest constituency of the World
Economic Forum has been part of well
really the second time but you know it's
been part of a forum event and come to
the India economic summit and I'm the
curator of the Mumbai hub of global
shapers and overall it's it's been
fantastic to see shapers from around the
country come in and bring their youth
voice into the discussion and contribute
things from that perspective